russia is in the grip of a third wave of
the coronavirus that's threatening to
overwhelm the country's health service
the capital moscow recorded 144 covet 19
deaths
in 24 hours on sunday that's the highest
rate since the beginning of the pandemic
and an average of twenty thousand new
infections are being reported across the
country each day
authorities are imposing strict new
measures to counter the surge as
dw's yuri rashetto reports
saint petersburg city beach couldn't be
busier
with temperatures above 30 degrees
celsius
thousands of russians have come to the
gulf of finland to escape the hot
weather and social distancing
russia is in the middle of its third
coronavirus wave
thanks to the rapidly spreading delta
variant the authorities are sounding the
alarm
the new mutation accounts for almost 90
percent of new cases
the situation with code 19 is explosive
we have had record numbers of new
infections the mortality statistics are
not looking good either
here
officials are talking about more than 20
000
new infections every day most of them in
moscow
to get the situation under control the
russian capital has
reopened field hospitals and built
medical stations
especially for coronavirus other
hospitals are quickly being re-equipped
to handle covet-19 patients
but their main goal is to get more
citizens vaccinated against covet 19.
russia was the first country in the
world to get a vaccine to market
with sputnik v so far however only 10
percent of the population has been
vaccinated
the government wants that to change by
degree
from now on all companies in moscow must
have at least
60 percent of their workforce vaccinated
the mayor is right everyone has to get
vaccinated to stop the coronavirus
they shouldn't force us they should try
to motivate us
the virus will spread less quickly this
way everyone should be vaccinated at
home
and get money for food at the same time
then we will all be healthy
restaurants are still open if only until
11 pm
but in the future only people who have
been vaccinated
have a medical certificate showing they
have recovered
or who have a negative pcr test will be
allowed to eat there
they will have to scan a qr code issued
by the moscow health authority
of course this means our turnover will
be much lower especially at the
beginning until the customers have
gotten used to it
but i think with each passing week we'll
feel relief with more and more people
getting vaccinated
but even these unprecedented measures
are a far cry from the tough lockdown
the government
imposed last year as infections began to
rise
virologists say it's a case of too
little
too late and that the third wave could
be russia's most devastating yet
and our moscow bureau chief yuri
roshetto filed a report joins us now
yuri how well equipped is the healthcare
system there in russia to handle this
third wave
well terry hopefully the russian health
system warned collapse at least here in
moscow all resources are currently being
activated
actually moscow survived the first two
corona waves very well despite
the quite high numbers of infections
both when it
comes to be to impatient and outpatient
treatment
i can speak only from my experience i
also had the coronavirus here and as a
patient
at home i received a lot of care from
russian doctors they came to examine me
several times at home and many
friends of mine experienced the same but
not
all of russia is like moscow the
situation in the rest country was often
much more dramatic last year and now we
are
unfortunately once again hearing about
overcrowded hospitals where passions are
placed
on mattresses in the hallways because
there are no bets left now yuri
russia was one of the first countries in
the world to develop and
export a coveted vaccine how can it be
that russia is now way behind other
countries and vaccinating its own people
there are several three reasons for that
uh when sputnik v came out
the russian vaccine had long been
considered unsafe not only in the west
but also in this country
uh the problem was that it was released
onto the market
too quickly before all the phases of the
clinical investigations
investigation were completed uh when
that changed and
the renowned renowned scientific
scientific
journal at the lancet finally announced
that it considered sputnik v to be
safe and effective hardly anyone here in
russia went to
get the vaccination because there was uh
hardly any advertising for it in moscow
there were
only a few posters that were not taken
seriously by anyone
but the main problem terry is that
russians simply have very little trust
in the state and much of what comes from
the state is not necessarily considered
safe
and finally the russian state has
downplayed the scale of the pandemic
very much in the past few months
the message in the past year has been
that russia has
almost achieved victory over the
coronavirus
okay it seems like authorities now are
putting a lot of emphasis
on vaccination the idea of a lockdown is
something they
seem to want to avoid do authorities
really think they can get through this
third wave
without a lockdown
well virus researchers say that there is
no way that these measures will
be enough to stop the third wave the
only thing they could
do is to minimize the extent of the
pandemic a bit
russians are not considered to be the
most disciplined people when it comes to
following rules and instructions from
the
for authorities we have seen this here
in moscow when it comes to wearing masks
in the subway and public places which is
a must people wear
the masks on their chins or simply in
their pockets so that they can't
be fined if they are checked but now the
moscow city government
has introduced new measures against
covet in restaurants starting today
only people who recovered from covet or
people who have been vaccinated are
allowed
in you can only get in with a qr code
which means you have to register with
the state health authority beforehand
then there is a requirement requirement
that all employees in the service sector
in moscow must be vaccinated and that 30
percent of all employees and companies
must work from
home but it's hardly possible to check
that
that measure is being carried and as i
said jerry the most important factor is
time and it seems that
the authorities may already be playing
catch up
yuri thank you very much our moscow
bureau chief yuri rochetto